everyone this is kevin from the chess
website com2 they're gonna be going over
an in-game tactic the queen verse the
rook decide what the queen is generally
going to win it's not always that easy
though number one goal is to separate
the King from the rook so that the side
with the Queen can capture the rook and
then go on to checkmate their opponent
this is a board setup of a very easy
victory many people would be able to
look at this and very quickly see Queen
to g6 wins the game we have a check and
this is also for King the rook right
here doesn't matter where the King moves
to the Queen can come down capture on b1
then we have a queen and king verse king
in game this is a very easy victory for
whites but not all the games are this
easy and if you're not familiar with the
50 move rule in chess if a pawn is not
moved or a piece is not being captured
and 50 moves the game is drawn and there
are definitely some positions with the
Queen verse that are not super easy and
making sure that you can do it under 50
moves can be a challenge if you don't
know how to do it so we're going to be
going over a few examples of how to
approach it how you can maneuver the
Queen around separate the King from the
rook I will also have a link in the
description below on the website there
are some practice boards so if you want
to go through play against the computer
see how well you do in different
variations we will have that for you as
well so let's go ahead and get into it
the first example we're gonna look at is
the Philidor position and it is White's
move trying to figure out how to win
here Black has done a good job of
barricading himself and it's tricky for
white to find a win but if it were
blacks move it really doesn't want to go
anywhere there's no good squares for
black to continue if he tries to move
his rook has doesn't have too many
options for his King just King over here
to c8 here roof to a7 that's gonna lose
Queen up to d8 that's checkmate if he
brings his rook to c7 you can see
capture here that's not gonna go
extremely well rook to d7 sometimes you
give up material because you want to
stalemate meaning your King can't move
now you have no legal moves and you're
not in check that's actually a drawn
games
don't want to be doing that too often
rook over here to e7
okay Queen up here d8 for king of the
rook the rook is going to fall if it
comes over here to f7 then you could
just play queen down to be four after
the king come c8 you bring queen to d6
there's no way to stop the threat here
yeah I could always bring your rook down
just sacrifice it but at the end of day
this is going to end in a checkmate if
we come back and say rook to g7
well then pretty easy fork to find here
on e5 and if we come back and say rook
to h7 same sort of thing there's no way
to hold on so you could play Queen to e5
maybe Queen a8 you could bring the Queen
down here to a1 King b8 and then you
could have the fork here on b1f if you
try to bring your rook to just this B
file maybe you look down to b3 Queen B 5
and then you could have Queen to c8 here
you have lots of different options but
Queen to e6 this is for King so there's
just no good move even if he decides to
play his king somewhere King to c8 well
then you just play Queen to a6 pinning
down the rook and there's no good move
so we can see that black has no good
moves
but it's White's move ideally we would
like to get to the same position but
have it be blacks move so really and
this in game the ideal move is to try to
maneuver to get to the same spot but
have it be blacksmith now in this
specific example the best move is going
to be Queen to e5 now if we see King to
c8 well then this is gonna be checkmate
right here there's no way to stop it if
instead maybe rook to c7
this is check also defending but then
Queen takes on c7 this is gonna be a
quick checkmate but
the other option would be King to a 8
and then Queen down here to a 1 and then
after King to be 8 then you could bring
your queen up here to a 5 and we have
the exact same position as before but
you can see in this example it is blacks
move now if we did come back and say why
don't we just bring our rook here to a 7
that is an option as well but then the
Queen comes up here to h8 and this is
going to be checkmate so once the queen
or king comes to b8 as we talked about
Queen to a5 and this is the Philidor
position but now it is blacks move so as
we looked at the very first example was
one move and there was a fork here you
can clearly see that there are some
positions that are much more complicated
another and trying to figure out the
best way to separate the king and the
rook or just find a a checkmate very
quickly can be pretty challenging last
example we'll look at shows that you
don't necessarily have to take the rook
if you find a mating opportunity which
mean times you will just go ahead and
execute and many of them are not as many
moves to fun in this example here it's
White's move you can see the rook and
the King are already pretty far away
which tends to mean that you have a much
stronger and easier in game but here
white can play Queen to d1 and the King
has no legal moves here if the rook was
off the board this would be checkmate
but he can bring his rook down to e1
you've limited the options that they
have here only one option you can see
from here the goal is to start to
separate the king and the rook a little
bit you could do that by playing Queen
to d3 only option is for I well you
could always bring your rook here to e2
but that's going to have a quick
checkmates here so if you don't want to
lose right away the only move would be
to bring your King over here to g1 but
now the move Queen to g6 this is going
to be deadly if you bring your
keen to either h1 or h2 both of those
are going to lose two Queen to g2 and if
you bring it back over here to f1 this
is going to be Queen down to g2 so at no
point that we actually take the rook
here on e1 but we did have a strong
attack that we found very early and that
ended in a checkmate so this is the
Queen verse rock there's so many
different variations I don't want to
make a hour-long video showing all of
those what I found a most valuable is to
just try out different in-game positions
and really start to train your brain to
find ways that you can maneuver the
Queen around the board and make sure you
can check may your opponent in under 50
moves many of them will be pretty quick
knowing that you can fork your
opponent's rook pretty easily so again
check out the link below in the video or
that will take you to the website the
chess website comm I do have six
practice boards for this a game also
have practice boards for all of the in
games many of those are for members so I
went ahead and set the expectations for
everyone if you go and you know like hey
many of these are members I do have one
designated that is not for member for
this in game so if if you're not if you
haven't been to the website recently and
you didn't even know that I've added all
those on there you could check it out
and one of those will be for non-members
so you can see how that plays out but
thank you guys so much for watching let
me know if you guys want other in-game
tactics to go over both on the videos or
on the website as well that you want to
practice the best way to send me
feedback whether it's a video you want
me to make it opening an in-game just
strategy in general is through email and
that is the chess website at gmail.com
I'll also have that in the description
below thank you guys so much for
watching the video I'll see you guys
next time